what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to a
video of a police officer
catching his wife cheating in a traffic
stop
sounds pretty interesting i'm excited to
see what happens but
before i start do not forget to like
comment and subscribe
let me know in the comments what is the
worst way that you have caught somebody
cheating
okay so
excuse me doing all right you understand
why i blew you over today
not not totally sure well this is
interesting
license and registration
oh he's getting a ticket what's going on
yeah anders there is
that all looks up today uh you know
i think oh i need to know what happens
oh my gosh guys i think i smell some
paraphernalia why don't i have you both
step out of the vehicle for me
yeah come on step out please keep your
hands where i can see them you too ma'am
step out of the vehicle uh no yeah you
can
come on out come on out ma'am i'm gonna
need you right around here on the back
sir put your hands on the hood going on
put your hands on the hood sir
right there right here yep and feet back
come back ma'am
right around here this way
yeah keep your hands right there
this has to be illegal yeah this has to
be illegal
so look at yeah me knife
you uh doing anything out here that you
shouldn't be doing follow my finger no i
mean i had a i had a glass of wine
hands out to the side and bring your
finger to
the tip of your nose slowly back out
one more time same hand now other hand
exact same time
okay do you know this woman how do you
know this woman
huh huh this is your first time
out with her oh really yeah
really damn
i'm curious why you're like why are you
asking about our dating oh damn
it's uh the only the only issue is that
that's my wife
pardon me yeah yeah you are part
i i will pardon you uh because i'm not
this is literally oh it's not a news
that's on you you're not the one that
made a tinder profile while you were
married
uh so hey can i put my hands down
you know why don't you put your hands
out why don't you uh grab her stuff out
of the car
and you can actually leave you go ahead
yeah yeah hop in heaven
over here yeah the driver said keep your
hands on the vehicle ma'am
why is she even talking oh my god
yeah i'm just going to rap yeah yeah
give me your stuff everything everything
that's hurt yeah why don't you give me
that
yep this right there yep her phone
good can i sit down uh yeah you go ahead
actually uh man step away from the
vehicle keep your hands up
excellent and uh you have a good one sir
i'm so sorry have
yes you are oh the poor guy
yep uh-huh
so did you really just i think
you and she said did you really ju like
you lady you made a tinder profile
well you you had a husband he's like out
here working
probably paying your bills and you're
doing this
there's nothing for you to say you're
gonna just stay here you should call
your mom
and have her get the rest of the things
from my place tonight
okay yeah this
was not how i was expecting my work day
to go
lady lady you have no room
to even complain yeah
a king a king he left her there
[Laughter]
no um that may have been illegal that
was my only caveat but oh my god that's
hilarious
um i hope he actually divorced her
let me know in the comments if you think
he went too far or if you think that was
a perfectly acceptable response
um don't forget to like comment and
subscribe i'll talk to you guys next
time